dimanche matin très tôt peu avant 3
heures du matin le centre opérationnel
de la gendarmerie nationale a été
destinataire d'un appel émanant d'une
jeune fille âgée de 15 ans et qui est
indiquée indiqué qu'elle venait de
découvrir le corps sans vie de sa maman
dès lors les services de secours
évidemment se sont immédiatement rendus
sur place et n'ont pu effectivement que
constater que cette maman était
effectivement décédé et l'examen externe
a permis de déterminer qu'elle avait été
atteinte de plusieurs coups
manifestement des coups de couteau qui
ont été portés au niveau du visage et du
cou de cette victime
bien que cela devra être précisés par
l'autopsié qui sera réalisée jeudi
l'indic c'est que au cours de la soirée
le compagnon qui était en cours de
séparation d'avec cette femme s'est
rendue à ce domicile
manifestement pour tenter d'avoir de
dialogue ou de discuter en tout cas sur
les recettes les raisons de cette
séparation est par la suite serait
auraient été évincés donc pas recette
cette maman mais serait revenu plus tard
dans la nuit et se serait alors rendu
dans la chambre de cette jeune fille
laquelle a immédiatement crié pour que
sa maman interviennent laquelle est
effectivement venu qui alors celle-ci
cette maman a tenté de faire appel aux
forces de l'ordre
et c'est alors que cet individu semble
avoir porté ses coups de couteau
par la suite donc cet individu a pu être
rapidement interpellé par les forces de
l'ordre et au cours de sa garde à vue et
il a pu effectivement confirmé dans une
très large partie les déclarations qui
émanait ainsi de cette jeune fille de 15
ans est justement son profil
alors il s'agit d'un individu âgé de 36
ans qui est originaire du lamentin qui
était ouvre qui est facilitée ouvriers
agricoles
et quelqu'un qui avait une condamnations
sur son casier judiciaire qu'il a été de
2011 et en 2011 il avait été condamné
pour des faits de menaces de mort déjà
au détriment d'une précédente compagne
l'intéressé a été donc présenté ce matin
à un juge d'instruction et le laquelle
est saisi de faits de d'homicide
volontaire aggravé par le fait que la
victime était son sa compagne ou son ex
compagne et d'autre part par le fait que
ce crime a été perpétré
concomitamment à un autre crime
est-ce qu'ils encourent il
il encourt une peine de réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
quel est le second crime auquel sa
division
alors voilà non non mais c'est voilà je
ne donnerai pas plus d'éléments sur sur
sur le reste de ce dossier